katia technique a eu des heurts qui ont
éclaté dans la capitale entre des
manifestants et les forces de l'ordre on
a pu voir des gars des forces de l'orde
intervenir à coups de gaz lacrymogènes
pour disperser les manifestants des
véhicules dégradés
katia technique quelle est la situation
de votre côté les tensions elles
perdurent on voit nous les forces de
l'ordre continuent et leurs
interventions pour tenter de disperser
les manifestants
ceux qui sèment le trouble oui en effet
mais en effet il ya des charges de très
nombreuses charges alors les les forces
de l'ordre qu ils reviennent beaucoup de
gaz lacrymogènes bon disons que ça reste
sur un certain périmètre et sinon les
les soignants sur les bords parce que
bon c'est quand même plutôt des des
éléments radicaux bien sûr qu'ils sont
aux prises avec les ports zélande les
autres soignants sont sur les côtés et
et attendent ils restent là parce que
c'est leur journée donc ils ne veulent
pas évidemment se disperser et sans
arrêt donc des charges se produisent les
gros nuages de gaz lacrymogènes mais
évidemment il faut garder en tête la
mobilisation principal la mobilisation
du jour une mobilisation nationale très
attendue pour porter des revendications
qui existe depuis déjà un an et demi je
suis avec le docteur enrico toby
chirurgien pédiatre alors docteur
aujourd'hui c'était c'est une journée de
plus pour exprimer à vos revendications
c'est quand même une journée
particulière parce que c'est la première
grosse ses premiers gros rassemblement
après l'épisode du coc vide et bon bain
une fois de plus on voit
on voit
ce qui est en train de se passer c'est à
dire on voit la considération qu'on peut
avoir nous les soignants sans ce général
c'est à dire que nos revendications
aujourd'hui pas plus qu'hier ne sont
écoutés par contre évidemment à la
moindre provocation hélas il ya quelques
black block qui provoque
bon bah voilà tout le monde prend du gaz
lacrymogène donc c'est c'est la
continuité mais c'est vrai que ça fait
quand même
assez mal après ce qui s'est passé en
france avec l'épidémie coville de voir
que des le premier rassemblement bon ben
voilà c'est le même traitement
inquiets qui est donnée donc un jour on
cogne sur les pompiers aujourd'hui c'est
des soignants c'est du grand n'importe
quoi
voilà ce qui se passe je suis pas
surpris parce que ça fait un moment que
ça dure
par contre l'espoir c'est que les gens
se rendent compte petit à petit de la
façon dont est gouvernée
voilà je pense que ça devient criant bon
après on peut toujours garder les yeux
fermés
mais à partir mans les ouvre ça devient
assez évident quand même nous ne sommes
pas écoutés
nos revendications ne sont pas prises en
compte cette histoire de ségur mais
penchez-vous un petit peu sur la façon
dont ça a été monté à toute vitesse
c'est de la rigolade
1 c'est de la rigolade voilà donc vous
trouvez que les revendications ne sont
pas prises en compte dans ce secteur là
pour l'est les premières retombées que
vous avez absolument absolument pas
c'est dire que c'est vraiment une fois
de plus un peu comme le grand débat un
pouvoir sur quoi le grand débat abouti
c'est c'est un pur scandale
renseignez vous pour savoir où sont les
doléances écrites les dizaines de
milliers de doléances écrites par les
français renseignez vous pour savoir où
elles sont aujourd'hui dans quelques là
car elles sont donc c'est tout
simplement pour meubler et pour essayer
de canaliser un petit peu cette colère
bien légitime qui a absolument partout
voilà bon aux gens de se rendre compte
dans quel
pays on vit sous quel type de régime en
vie c'est c'est ça devient complètement
inacceptable voilà bon moi ça fait un
moment que je n'accepte plus
on va être de plus en plus nombreux
c'est juste évident et si les réponses
qu'on a à chaque fois c'est ce type de
réponse c'est à dire que on a une une
police qui étiez comme ça agressive
bon ça va rien arranger c'est pas comme
ça qu'on va régler le problème il ya des
problèmes de fond à partir de quand on
les aborde réellement et je peux vous
dire que ce ségur vous verrez bien
rendez vous dans trois mois vous verrez
ça va déboucher sur rien la différence
avec avancé qu on le sait maintenant on
sait voilà c'est pas comme ça que on
arrivera à changé dans le fond les
problèmes de fond qui existe avec cette
épidémie tco vide
tout le monde a pu se rendre compte que
l'hôpital public a été en partie
démantelé on est en sous-effectif on est
incapable de faire face la santé en
france soit disant la meilleure du monde
le monde entier a vu ce que c'était a vu
qu'on est dans une situation extrêmement
dégradée
voilà bon donc ça c'est le problème de
fond est ce qu'on l'a borg ou est-ce
qu'on n'aborde pas merci beaucoup
monsieur dr kotô been nous avoir fait
part de vos impressions évidemment delà
de l'amertume 1 lors de cette
manifestation qui a tourné finalement à
l'affrontement
en espérant que les revendications
aujourd'hui des soignants sont tout de
même audible entendues notamment dans ce
contexte de ségur et pour la situation
ici qui a l'air de se calmer un peu nous
vous tiendrons au courant au fur et à
mesure
ou à vocation technique